up um so first we'll have martha and
martha white
uh give a talk and then we'll have the
discussion figured
thank you uh for talking today and
looking forward to hearing your talk
please take it away
great thanks mark so like mark said i'm
martha white i'm at the university of
alberta and today i'm going to talk a
little bit about how we're going to
generalize
this objective called the projected
belmonaro it's an objective near and
dear to my heart but mostly been used
for the linear setting
and how we're going to do that in a nice
sound wave for the non-linear setting of
course this is a workshop about deep rl
so we want to ask how can we take some
of our really nice theory and
formalisms from the linear function
approximation setting and bring it as
much as possible to the non-linear
function approximation setting
all right so this is 20 minutes is very
short i actually have lots of things
that i want to tell you because there's
been some really nice developments in
this area
um actually lots of cool stuff from bo
dai and lee hong actually that i'm going
to be
giving call outs to in this talk so i'm
going to try to go at a reasonably fast
pace knowing that we're going to have 10
minutes at the end
or we can always go back and ask more
questions and look at specific slides
okay so what's my goal my goal here is
to estimate values i'm going to talk
mostly about the prediction setting so
we're going to be estimating
v pi with some approximation v but
actually a lot of this stuff extends
also to the control setting
but let's let's make it more
straightforward and talk first about
prediction so my goal is to estimate
this v
pi if we could we'd minimize this value
error objective
but we can't actually directly optimize
this objective and here usually in this
objective we're also going to have this
waiting over states where the weighting
is given by some d that tells me how i
want to trade off my function
approximation resources
okay so we can't directly optimize this
objective so a lot of questions that
arise for the value estimation
problem is well then what objectives
should we use and so there's a long
history here trying to understand what
kind of objectives should we use for a
value estimation
and in fact even a sound off policy
evaluate estimation was an open problem
for quite some time you know everyone
used td td is a beautiful algorithm q
learning is a beautiful algorithm they
have stood the test of time
but yet we know they have soundness
problems so there was a lot of progress
made though once uh
there's an introduction of an objective
called the mean squared projected
bellman error
so i'm going to be calling that pbe with
a line above it for mean
okay and then there's this just
explosion of many different gradient
algorithms that uh that
we could say things about how sound they
were for value estimation and it is
beautiful
that and still we sort of have a few
open questions so um
one thing is is that this projective
element error is largely defined for the
linear setting
most of the algorithms are derived for
the linear setting
and uh there is actually one nice work
about the nonlinear project development
error
from chaba and hamid and um
they sort of do this natural thing where
they use like a local linear
approximation but the
resulting algorithm ends up being a
little more complex we take gradients
through gradients you get hessian vector
products
and those actually quite a nice
algorithm we've tried it it can perform
well in practice
um it hasn't had a lot of uptake i think
because of this complexity
and on the flip side so now we know we
are asking how are we going to bring
some of this stuff to the nonlinear case
the bellman error has always been
applicable to both we could use it for
the non-linear or linear setting
in the project development operator the
project development operator uses
a projection that's harder to compute
for the nonlinear setting which is one
of the reasons we've been using it so
much in the linear setting
but the bellman error has its own
problem so one thing for a very long
time is that it was considered difficult
to optimize
because of the double sampling problem
and and so i think that was one of the
reasons it was sort of put to the side
and the projector bobbin error explored
more
and then more recently also rich in his
book has shown that it has some
identifiability issues as well which is
you know read here for a reason as well
that's problematic
so we're sort of in this case where we
don't know we didn't know how to use the
bellman era the projected belmoner was a
bit harder to extend in the non-linear
setting and now there's actually
recently been some really nice
developments
uh reformulating the belmont air with
the conjugate form from body and lihong
and
and others that i think is very
promising and that's what this talk is
going to build on those nice positive
developments
okay so what i'm going to what i'd like
to try to motivate in this is that we
want to figure out how to extend
the linear projected bellman era to the
non-linear case
and so and particularly because we care
about non-linear function approximation
and we want to ask what is the right
objective
so it's a sort of a big question it's
always a strong thing to say what is the
best thing or the right thing
but i'm going to say that my answer that
i'm going to try to make a pitch for in
this talk
is that a good objective for nonlinear
function
approximation is this thing i'm going to
call the generalized projected bellman
error
i'm giving a name to something that sort
of already exists in the literature
and specifically that we when we're
picking this objective when we want it
to be the right objective we're going to
have to pay
attention to the the choice of weighting
we have in that objective
and that choice of weighting might
actually be different than the
actual true ideal weighting we care
about in our value
so let me tell you more about both of
these things okay so the outline of my
talk i'm going to mainly try to get
across these three things first i'm
going to show you what is this
generalized projected belmonaro that
lets us go from the linear case to the
more general setting
um then i'll talk about why is this why
should we care about this state waiting
like why is that something that's worth
a high priority of our time
and the last thing is now that we have
this objective
we still want to ask how is it going to
be practical to use in practice
and uh and there's at least two ways
that we could try to optimize this
objective
and i think one of those ways is going
to be a much more promising direction
that makes it more likely that this
objective will actually be adopted in
practice okay and then if there's time
then i'll actually show you some
positive empirical results
this paper is not yet published but it's
sort of an extension of an icml paper
from this year and i have a working
paper up on my website if you'd like to
go
check it out and otherwise i also have
the slides for this talk on my website
okay good let's start with the first
thing let's start by driving this
journalized projected dominar
okay so to derive this we're really just
going to rely on um
this beautiful result from bo dai and
others from a paper called learning from
conditional embedding
this title here um and so really this
does most of the heavy lifting forms
and we're just going to take these ideas
and just do the sort of natural small
next step and define a few things that's
going to help us make some traction in
this problem so if you haven't read this
paper you should go look at this paper
and follow up papers from lee han about
speed and about the carmen
colonel bellman error and now also
nanjang just posted a cool paper earlier
that's related as well
so the really nice insight from this
work is that
we can take the bellman air and we can
reformulate it as a saddle point problem
so it's going to have this mid max form
where we have an inner maximization over
this auxiliary variable h
and that h variable is this is
estimating some part of the objective
okay now with that form you know h is
giving us an estimate
um but we want to get as close as
possible to the true bellman er so
there's these nice
results that show that we can use
different estimation approaches for each
for example
non-parametric approaches and get a
really close estimate to the belmont
okay so the key insight for us here is
that this this line of work is
actually getting us now practical
algorithms to nearly optimize the
bellman error where we can get a really
close approximation to the bellman error
but there is still going to be some
approximation
so it sort of reopens up the avenue to
non-linear value estimation because
now we can start looking at the belmont
error which more naturally applies to
the non-linear setting
so that's sort of the direction i was
going there is how can we do as good of
a job estimating the bellman error as
possible and and optimizing that
and we're going to i'm going to go just
a slightly different direction and ask
how can we use this to derive a
generalization to the linear projected
belmont
so that's what we're going to do so
let's we're going to build on this work
and go in that direction
um mostly i'm going to take what was
already in that work and just formalize
it in the language of
projection so that and so that we can
more easily talk about some of the
algorithm
algorithmic strategies used for the
linear projective eliminator
okay we're going to talk about the
finite state case here's some notation
we're going to use
so i'm going to assume we have a
parametrized value function b hat with
parameters w
know here's the standard td error and
just note that when i talk about
expected value of the td
error parameterized by the weights under
policy pi
um you know that's exactly reflecting
what this bellman residual is so it's
just the spelman operator here but i'm
going to be often writing it in this
form instead because it's going to be
useful for manipulation
okay great this is actually sort of an
educational talk so i wish you could
interrupt me as we go along but maybe
if someone really has a burning question
or clarification i actually can pay
attention to chat as we go and i might
be able to respond
okay so the steps for this are actually
very simple which is one of the things i
love about it
so first let's just write out what the
bellman errors this first line is just
the definition of the bellman error
we're looking at for across all states
weighted according to d so this outer
sum is an expectation over states we're
just asking what's my expected um
bellman error in from that state
according to policy pi
now the first step we're just going to
rewrite this using this conjugate form
here so
when we look at the squared squared
function the conjugate form looks
exactly like this where we just
we can rewrite it with the max over a
different variable h and here now our y
just corresponds to this term that's the
thing that's being squared
so that's what you see exactly here this
is our y we just have an h we're
maximizing over h
okay so first step is apply the
conjugate form and then the next step
is that we can bring the smacks outside
of the sum as long as
our h can represent the same h's that we
would need it to represent so
here we have a finite state case as long
as we have the space of all functions
then our h
of s we can always set it to be equal to
what we needed it to be in this inner
term so we can pull it out
and in fact we know exactly what this
optimal h is for this maximization
h of s here is trying to approximate
this expected
uh td error so if we if we use that h
then
um that's exactly the h that would be
picked for this inner term
okay that's the that's it that's the
reformulation and now we might ask why
is this a useful thing well
the useful thing now is that we have two
variables but this auxiliary variable
makes it really easy to compute the
gradient for w so if i give you
an estimate h then now the objective
this inner term here i have two
variables a w and h that's being stacked
we have this min max form and the
computing the gradient of this
term h is you know some constant and you
just compute the gradient here with
respect to w
and that's straightforward it's exactly
this term
so we can now get a stochastic sample of
our gradient by computing the gradient
of the delta and h of s is representing
this
expected value of delta out in front and
now we can just learn these two things
together our h for example can
it might not even need a learning you
might just estimate it using some
non-parametric approach
okay so that's why it's useful now you
might say okay then
aren't we done we now can optimize the
bellman er straightforward i'm going to
apply it to my neural network i just
need to estimate this extra h somehow
um but the the first point is that i
already mentioned that there is one
other problem which is that the bellman
error is non-identifiable
and so we're going to go a little bit
further we're going to talk a little bit
about what should we pick for h that's
going to help us resolve
um this question but not identifiability
and then move to this generalized
projected bone there
okay so this is going to feel a little
bit like an aside about but one thing is
that i think it's kind of fun to talk
about this non-identifiability problem
but it also naturally sets up to
the projection okay so um the first
thing we can do is we can
we can notice that we can actually get a
natural identifiable bellman error by
using this conjugate form
uh you may not know about this problem
with development error there's this nice
example from the sutton and bartok book
that i've linked that referenced here
that simply shows that if
if you had this partial observable
setting so if you have a data stream or
the agent
might be saying one of these two mdps
but it has no idea it just sees
that it always gets this observation bit
that's equal to one
so the data stream between these two
mdps for the agent is going to look
exactly the same
so we couldn't hope that it's going to
learn a different solution on those
two things because the data stream looks
exactly the same but the true solution
to the mean square objective almond
error
for these two settings is different okay
so that's what the counter
example shows and really the issue here
is that the belmonaro is defined on
quantities that are not available in the
data
uh and so what what we can see is that
sort of the way to talk about in the
conjugate form is that the
h is defined on quantities that are not
available in the data but the h is now a
variable that of course we are trying to
estimate so it makes
no sense to define h on quantities that
are not available in the data
because i hope that's intuitive so
the natural thing to actually have to
find our bellman era as is for this h to
be defined
only as the set of functions on the
space
that is actually given to the agent so
we're still going to allow h to be any
any function it wants it can be a crazy
function it can be a non-parametric
function but it's only allowed to take
as inputs
the actual information that's in the
data and then now we're going to remove
this identifiability problem
because that's sort of one neat thing
that the conjugate form gives us um
and the other but then it's also sort of
starting to highlight
well then you know maybe we don't just
want to restrict h
this way what happens if we continue to
restrict h
and that's going to bring us to our
generalized belmont error so more
generally as we start restricting the
function space for h
we're going to get a projection on the
development error and that's going to
give us our generalized projected
element
so just to explain some of the notation
on this slide here i'm just writing what
this projection means so this is saying
that this is the projection of some
vector u onto the
space h the function space h here with
weighting d
so it's saying go find the h that's the
closest to you in my space h
weighted proportionally to d okay that's
what that's this projection operator
does
so if we take this what i'm going to now
just immediately define as the
generalized
projected bellman error and we're just
saying i picked some space
h this h no longer has to be h all
that's the all was dropped from here
could be more restricted then we're
going to you know do multiple steps and
find that we can this gets rewritten
exactly as this projection of our
bellman error okay and so
um this is called i'm calling this a
generalized projected bellman error
because you know by picking different
choices of h you sort of get some of
these natural settings that we're used
to so
if i pick h here equal to the same space
as the value function space
and it's equal to a linear function
space so they're both a linear function
space
then this actually gives us exactly the
linear projective element error
if otherwise though we can actually
generalize them both to a nonlinear
function space and then that gives us
what is a natural extension of the
linear projected domain error
to the nonlinear setting um we've
already seen that if we restrict h all
then we're going to get an identifiable
bellman error so we can kind of think of
this identifiable bellman air also as a
projected bellman er
and then more generally we could have
this whole space of possible
projective element errors if we pick an
h that's a larger
function space than the space for our
value function
okay um
this seems like there's a fun discussion
going in the chat but i'm going to have
to keep going okay so that
that's that was the first thing i want
to tell you is here's a natural way that
we can generalize
to get a generalized projected belmonaro
just by using these beautiful insights
about how we're going to approximate the
bellman er
okay next next point so let given that
we have that objective
now we can ask one more important
question so i should say here i've kind
of highlighted the importance of this
choice how should we restrict
h and then of course another thing here
that i haven't mentioned is d
so i think d is sort of something that's
often overlooked for
value estimation especially in
prediction and control the weighting is
much more focused on
but um in in value estimation
we might want to ask a little more about
this so to make to sort of understand
what should we pick for d
what we really want to do is turn to
some of these nice value error bounds
that exist in the literature that can
give us some insights about
um what is the role of d and getting
good bounds on the value error
so let me explain this result here this
is just saying
that um if i get my value
function from my generalized projected
bellman era so this is not about
you know any kind of approximation
saying if i got the actual true solution
for my generalized projectile or that
true fixed point
and i want to know how far is it from
the true value b pi
then um this can be upper bounded by
this worst case approximation error so
this term
here is just um this is saying get the
closest point in my function space
f that's the best i could have hoped to
do by projecting b pi
so this is my approximation error and
then i'm going to add some constant out
in front here
um okay and so in for this constant uh
this is just telling us what the norm is
of our projection i'm going to not going
to focus on that right now
but the the key thing is that we of
course like this constant to be small
and particularly we would like it to be
bounded
but uh actually if we're not careful
about our choice of d
um this this this side can actually get
um
this norm here can actually get very bad
so let me give you an example so there's
this really beautiful
counter example from zico coulter where
it just takes a very simple two-state
mdp
it has very small approximation error so
the value function
space that you have can actually very
nearly approximate the true v
pi and what he shows that if you take a
d that corresponds to the off policy
stationary distribution so equal to
let's call it db
then the solution from the projective
element error can have arbitrarily bad
value error so even though you're
weighting the value error by db you go
and compute the optimal projected
bellman era solution
also weighted by db you can make that
number shoot off
you can make the value error get worse
and worse and worse by making some
choices in your behavior
it's a pretty cool counter example so
what this is telling us is that just
picking just saying you know it's
probably okay if i just use the
stationary distribution for the behavior
policy well the answer is it might not
be okay it might actually be really
really bad
and uh and but what we can't one thing
we can do
is so there's this work on emphatic
weightings um
lee hong mentioned them where we can
actually make some guarantees that
we will have these nice bounded
constants here and we will have
a upper bound on the value error for our
miscarriage projected belmont error
solution if we use a different weighting
okay so this first result is saying if i
change my weighting d
from the state from db to this other
thing called an emphatic weighting
then um i will actually get this nice
result that says i have some upper bound
on my value error that's just
proportional to the approximation error
times some constant and this constant
sort of reasonable and then we can say
something even more interesting i think
which is you know sort of cheating that
we get to pick our weighting and our
objective
and we get to pick our weighting in our
evaluation you know
what if i just picked all weight on one
state and then i can easily satisfy this
uh so you can additionally say if i gave
you agnostically some other wing let's
say i gave you here this stationary
distribution weighting that kind of
covers the space reasonably
even under that weighting even though i
optimally up
optimize my objective according to the
synthetic weighting i still get this
nice upper bound on this value
again you know there's only so many so
much we know actually about what these
constants look like um
but we we've also been running a few
experiments to see if some of this stuff
happens in practice as well
and oh i'm really running out of time so
i'm going to quickly just summarize what
this slide is saying
so this what all this is saying is we
ran with the projected belmont our
bellman air across many different
problems with different feature spaces
and the sort of key conclusion here is
that when we optimize
our objective with the stationary
distribution weighting
this dark color is bad and so the error
is bad in general
even when we use the weighting db and
the true value error
which is what this is showing on this
side and when we change the weighting in
our objective it significantly improves
the quality of our solution
this is not about optimization online or
anything it's really just about where do
you converge to so even if you have the
best algorithm it really optimizes your
objective well
if you're not careful about waiting
you're going to converge to a poor
solution
okay the last thing i'll do and i think
i can summarize this quickly in one
minute
so we sort of have what i think is a
reasonable choice for the objective for
non-linear value estimation
and then to make it practical i think
there's one other important point which
is
when we're sampling this grading for
this objective we want to make sure
we are not too reliant on how accurate
our estimate h is
okay so let me uh there's sort of two
two different types of
strategies that people typically use for
the linear projected bellman er
to get a sample of the gradient one is
this saddle point update and the other
is this gradient correction update
so if you're sort of used to this
literature the first one corresponds to
gtd2 and the second corresponds to tdc
and uh this one is just a gradient i
showed you earlier
it's taking our estimate h and it's
computing this gradient of the td error
one thing you'll notice about this
update is that it relies heavily on
h so imagine you start h near zero or
like you know it's randomly initialized
near zero
the early updates to w are going to be
pretty poor because
it's being modulated fully by this each
the gradient correction update instead
moves a few terms around and and gets an
update that looks like this where the
first part always includes a true
unbiased sample so it has this td error
term here
and then you only use the h and what is
this gradient correction term so it
relies a lot less on the estimate for
age
okay there's a there's a some nice
reason to think that's a good idea and
experiments are just a good idea there's
some more difficulty in analyzing the
gradient correction update because it's
not really a true gradient update
anymore
but we have just found consistently that
this is the right direction to go
and there's nicely some of the analysis
of how to derive the grading correction
update
actually extends to the non-linear case
as well we go through this in the
working paper
uh and it's just a natural way to try to
estimate this h in the null in your
setting so that's what we used in the
icml paper
um the the very simple idea is just to
take
q learning let's say we did prediction
and control but let's i'll just tell you
the control one
you can just take something like q
learning grading and corrections where
you would do your usual thing you have
the screen part of the network that's
your usual q-learning agent
all you do is add an extra head to the
network that's going to estimate h
none of these gradients flow back which
is what's suggested by the analysis it
actually just suggests
better to put this extra head on the
network and then these
action values are updated with the
gradient correction form
okay so the exciting result that we
found was that um
gradient methods actually seem to help
so both qc and qrc uh
the r just means regularized corrections
but they're both using this
you know network structure i just showed
you here um
they actually both perform outperform q
learning
uh and in some cases by quite a lot so
for us this was really amazing and
surprising
because one thing we often find when we
learn experiments is that q learning and
td perform pretty well and it's pretty
hard to outperform them actually
so um this is an exciting exciting
result for us that gradient methods were
actually helping
okay so let me just conclude with the
summary
so really these are the main points that
i wanted to get across today one is that
the generalized projected dominar is a
natural extension of the linear
projected belmonaro to the nonlinear
setting
there's this additional nice benefit
that this projector belmonaire helps
resolve questions about development
error both about identifiability and how
it's connected to the linear projected
eliminator
and whenever you're running these
algorithms um
the role the weighting shouldn't be
overlooked because you might actually
find it impacts your performance a lot
all right thank you very much
okay thanks a lot this is really
interesting talk um
um so we have a few minutes for uh
questions i open the floor for questions
now
let's do that i'm just going to start
going through chat i see a mira masseuse
question about how is the generalized
projected bombing are different from the
nested optimization given by
chaba muhammad shah and you had a few
years ago
yeah actually i'm going to agree with
nanjiang um
i would love to see that formulation i
know there's a lot of work in this area
so
maybe you're there's also the antos
paper i could tell it's a little bit
related to that
it is definitely related to several
papers and i'd love to tell you more so
one thing i do want to emphasize here is
that
a lot of what i've talked about today is
sort of summarizing a larger body of
work that is exploring these questions
and by going to the working paper it
more emphasizes how this is relying on a
lot of important results these other
papers and you can go find those results
in those other papers
so uh martha great talk i have a
question about the
the weight correction thing i think i
understand its role
and the you know policy evaluation sorry
in the evaluation setting
uh but for the optimization and control
setting
uh what's the i mean i i may have like
missed that part
is the recommendations due to like
correct to the
um to the distribution that would be
induced by your current policy or
what yeah great question so you mean up
here i've made the comment that the
emphatic weighting makes
the fixed point for the music ejection
i'm on or better for the value setting
and for the control setting i still have
no idea so the control setting for me is
newer
i'm not even sure exactly how you define
the emphatic waiting because your policy
is changing all the time
like you said you could define it to be
the current policy synthetic weighting
but um but i know i don't know how what
that means for the bellman optimality
form yeah so so actually we have some
work like in the earlier paper we sent
out uh we have some
like there's some pretty simple analysis
that you can show that
in the control setting what matters uh
the
the the distribution induced by your
current policy matters
but still the distribution of the
optimal policy also matters
it's like these two things like together
or whatever policy you want to compete
with
it's like these the bellman error under
both these distributions
give you a tight control over the
subliminality of your policy
so that's what i feel like in the
control setting you may not want to like
directly just completely like uh
re-weight to
the the the on policy distribution of
your current policy
right right it is true that the control
setting is a little different because
here at least when we're talking about
the value estimation setting
then we sort of have two similar-ish
things on both sides of the equation
like we are trying to estimate some
values v but in this
in the control setting you're saying how
good is my policy but i'm but then
you're looking at like bellman errors
which are
more different but anyway i i was i was
actually reading your paper right before
this talk since you mentioned it
and it looks like it's full of lots of
really nice results that maybe we could
try to incorporate into the
working paper because one of my goals
actually for the working paper is to go
and summarize
all these different ways people have
tried to bound these errors
and see what we can do to extend for
this for this particular thing
martha we have a question from the
attendees did you see that question
okay let me pull up the you mean like
there's a q a
okay let me just i always have to get
one second
the last one about projection operator
i have this okay there we go i have this
thing where i hover over
the top panel and it takes forever to
show up okay um
okay gary gays agree with me i felt like
i was the only one who had this problem
is the projection operator contraction
for the non-linear setting
and if yes what are the assumptions and
if it's a contraction
uh okay good question so the whenever we
write down the projection
oh okay maybe maybe what you mean is is
like the projected bellman operator a
contraction for the nominee you're
setting like when we're when we whenever
we talk about
doing um like bellman fix point
iterations we're sort of imagining we're
doing this
um iteration of the development operator
and the muscular project development in
case you sort of analyze what's the
properties of the projected bellman
operator maybe that's what the question
is there um actually when we talk about
this projection
uh then it still actually applies for
the nonlinear setting like you can
characterize the projected bellman
operator for the nonlinear setting in
the sense that our function space can be
a general function space
so then in that case the projected
bellman operator
can be a contraction and in some cases
we know that it is not a contraction say
for example some cases in the off policy
setting
that if that answers that question yeah
well i suppose that the question should
be
whether this is and this projection
operator that you have is a
non-expansion or not
right right can it can it happen that it
is going to like throw further away the
arguments that they were before and i
guess the answer for that is as long as
your function
class is convex which means that it
includes all the comics combinations of
the functions
that i think this should hold right
right exactly
it's not a linear versus a non-linear
thing
i have a question because sometimes
you use two different functions based
and my question is
is it related to the obvious projection
point of view of
learning value function if you know it
the interesting what the big projection
point of view is basically is
what you want to do is ready to project
the very function but you don't have the
value function so you can do a
project you can minimize the residual
you can do lstd which is a projection
[Music]
function of the projection and if you
change the
if you take a space and you change uh
you do an object projection which is
orthogonal according to the seven of the
hypothesis space you can recover the
true value function but uh
it's circular in the sense that finding
this hypothesis space is as hard as
finding the
function so is it related to this kind
of approach
i didn't hear all of that but i'm going
to start off by saying definitely that
some this for example this projection
operator and this result is
is simply writing some of the results
for this case that sharer has and that
like
jane eu and brothers have about oblique
projections because here this is exactly
oblique projections
h is this non-diagonal matrix okay and
then i think you said when it comes to
choosing that space
um there's some circular thing going on
but you cut us i didn't exactly hear
what you said there
yes yes that's what i was saying
we can say what the optimal space for
the
projection is but knowing this optimal
space workly requires knowing the value
function which is
what you try to estimate so the
question is how to choose this space
right i agree okay now now i understand
um that comes back to the how do we
choose that h
said and i don't i honestly don't have a
great answer for you i'm not sure yet
what we should choose
i'm going to hypothesize that like li
hong and bo
uh and others have said we should try to
make that project that space
h as big as possible we want to project
as little as possible
maybe putting words in their mouth
whereas my proposal is that that h space
should actually be parameterized using
the gradient of the value function for
the state because that seems to give us
this nice algorithm that we can
that performs well in practice with this
gradient correction update even though i
know that that means we're restricting
our space
h more what we really what i would
really like to do is see if we can say
something more general about
about it from the theory but that i
don't know yet how to do
yes
okay maybe we have a plan for one more
quick question
before we move on to the discussion
session um
um
um so maybe i can take the uh the
opportunity to ask the question i
always have about the uh the example in
uh that mother you mentioned earlier in
the talk that um there is an
example a simple example where uh yeah
exactly this
non-identifiable common error do you
think this is a
very serious issue by using government
error as a
objective function this is quite common
in other learning problems is supervised
learning right
we don't expect identifiability but it
seems things
work pretty well there could you
elaborate a little bit more on that
actually for me the conclusion from this
is um the people who are optimizing the
bellman era are doing the right thing
and also this example is also sort of
right and
in some sense we're all trying to just
do this slight modification which is the
identifiable
bellman error so in some sense this is
like a win for everyone we were all
right
that's kind of how i feel about this
answer um
but anyway i guess is it a serious
problem i think in most cases
uh we maybe aren't actually going to see
this problem like when we're when we are
trying to approximate the bellman error
online
with all the strategies that are
currently being used i think implicitly
they are optimizing the identifiable
bellman era
is what's going to happen um
so i don't know i'm not sure if that
really answers your question actually
yeah um it's it's sort of um and this
question may be uh it may be more
appropriate to discuss and
later on perhaps in the discussion
session and since we're running out time
so maybe uh it's time to move on to
discussion and now and and thank mother
again for the talk
and uh without further ado i'll let go
to take control
of the discussion thanks
all right all right that's wonderful
thank you lee hong and thank you mark
for uh for inviting me to host this and
thanks
for the wonderful talks so far today
this
afternoon i would say for me